[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur france 24 à la
une ce soir ce bilan au burkina faso vit
civils ont été tués dans l'est du pays
lors d'une attaque jihadiste pendant un
baptême deux autres attaques ont
également eu lieu dimanche dans le nord
du pays nous évoquons entre autres la
question sécuritaire avec notre invité
le ministre burkinabè de l'éducation
porte parole du gouvernement
lionel bilgo
la condamnation par l'onu des violences
contre les migrants par le maroc et
l'espagne à mellila cette enclave
espagnole située sur le territoire
marocain son porte-parole stéphane
dujarric dénonce un usage excessif de la
force ayant entraîné des dizaines de
morts il appelle à l'ouverture d'une
enquête et puis nous irons en egypte où
le gouvernement a ordonné aux habitants
d'une trentaine de maisons bateaux
d'évacuer les lieux au plus tard le 4
juillet les occupants de ces maisons
flottantes ne comprennent pas cette
décision reportage à suivre
les victimes participaient à un baptême
lorsque des hommes armés ont fait
irruption et leur ont tiré dessus une
attaque menée par des djihadistes
présumés dans une localité située dans
une province dans l'est du burkina faso
deux autres attaques ont été menées ce
dimanche dans le nord du pays la
situation sécuritaire est très
préoccupante et pour en parler nous
recevons ce soir lionel bilbao ministre
burkinabè des ducs et de l'éducation
porte parole du gouvernement merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous sur ce plateau
alors je parlais de cette attaque on
voit que les attaques ne cessent pas
qu'elles se multiplient où en est la
situation sécuritaire dans votre pays
depuis la prise de pouvoir du
lieutenant-colonel damiba oui c'est vrai
on peut remarquer que les attaques se
multiplient mais on peut aussi dire que
ce sont des attaques de représailles du
fait donc la montée en puissance de
l'armée burkinabè de la nouvelle
stratégie mise en pratique depuis un an
et demi par l'armée burkinabè qui a
quand même opérer une saignée très dur
dans les rangs des terroristes
on voit vraiment que les terroristes
sont acculés et malmené dans certaines
zones de notre pays et donc ça amène en
tout cas à des actions de représailles
quand on voit la violence des attaques
on voit ligne omni de ces attaques là on
peut dire qu'on ne les avait jamais vus
en tout cas y'a plus du tri sélectif
on ne s'attaque plus qu'à d'alarmé au
cas des militaires mais tout simplement
à des civils qui n'ont rien fait que du
vivant paisiblement dans leur localité
alors vous parlez de votre nouvelle
stratégie vous avez annoncé il ya
quelques semaines la création de zones
d'intérêt militaire en quoi ça consiste
exactement et pourquoi cette initiative
il faut savoir que les groupes
terroristes ont pris 1,1 des positions
fortes en fait dans l'est du pays et
dans les salles du pays l'est du pays
c'est à peu près 17 points 5 % du
territoire burkinabè c'est une région
assez grand et assez large avec pas mal
de fourrer à son sein et donc c'est le
bastion de certains groupes terroristes
armés les populations avaient déjà fui
ces localités depuis un bout de temps et
donc l'armée a décidé de concentrer ses
efforts allaient chercher on n'est plus
dans une défensive mais dans une vraie
offensive vers les nids de terroristes
aller les chercher là où ils sont pour
les déloger les débuts x débusquer c'est
cette stratégie qui va être mis en place
et pour garder quand même un visage
humain à ce conflit et ne pas créer
autant de dégâts collatéraux comme on le
voit ailleurs l'armée a prévenu et a
demandé justement aux populations qui
sont encore restés dans ces localités de
quitter sa localité tout ans a changé le
précise qu'il y a peu de personnes
civiles dans ces localités parce que
dupuis au bout du temps il ya eu une
exode massif de ces populations vers des
zones sécurisées alors la transition a
été fixé à 36 mois par des assises
nationales la cedeao préconise une
période de transition acceptable le
sommet de l'organisation ouest africaine
est prévue ce dimanche 3 juillet comment
l'appréhendez vous écoutez au niveau du
gouvernement burkinabè nous sommes dans
une sérénité sans pareil parce que nous
l'avons toujours dit la cedeao et emme
est un bel instrument que le burkina
faso voudrait encore voir agir en son
sein et agir au sein de la cedeao nous
ne comptons pas nous mettre en marge de
l'organisation
internationale ou des institutions
internationales nous voulons tout
simplement que le cas du burkina soit
étudiée de façon minutieuse et avec une
objectivité sans pareil c'est pour ça
que le burkina faso a demandé à la
cedeao de venir sur le terrain est de
constater d'elle-même les difficultés
que nous avons la question qui se pose
sur la durée effective le terme
acceptable nous l'avons demandé il faut
mettre du contenu dans ce terme
acceptable et je crois que la cedeao est
dans une bonne prédisposition le burkina
aussi les discussions se sont mené de
façon apaisée de façon consensuelle et
je crois fermement que nous tendons vers
vraiment une solution consensuelle pour
permettre au burkina faso d'exister
encore et à la cedeao dû participer à
l'effort de guerre que fait le burkina
faso depuis bientôt quelques mois en
tout cas on suivra ce sommet de la
cedeao qui aura lieu ce dimanche 3
juillet alors on prend on en parlait
tout à l'heure hors plateau le
terrorisme l'insécurité ne provoque pas
que des bilans humains des morts même si
c'est déplorable et c'est un drame ça
provoque d'autres conséquences graves
comme par exemple les luttes
intercommunautaires des tensions
intercommunautaires récemment des appels
à la violence à l'encontre de certaines
communautés ont circulé sur les réseaux
sociaux vous avez votre gouvernement a
rapidement réagi par un communiqué vous
avez peur de cet insecte que cette
insécurité
finissent par menacer la cohésion
sociale au burkina faso vous savez au
burkina faso nous faisons face à deux
guerres une première guerre qui a lu
terrorisme connu tous et une deuxième
guerre qui est une guerre fraticide une
fracture sociale qui dure depuis des
années que nous transmettons de père en
fils de façon héréditaire et il nous
faut ensemble avec la plus grande
volonté mais aussi le plus grand courage
affronter se demande de conflits
fratricides pour aller vers
véritablement une réconciliation soyeux
nous plaît et regarder l'objectif
principal qui est de maintenir l'unicité
de notre territoire et vous savez tant
qu'on ne va pas prendre ce problème à
bras le corps est temps que la
communauté internationale dans son
ensemble ne va pas se pencher sur le cas
du sahel je pense que nous courons vers
du grand d'armes drame comme vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure il n'y a pas que les
morts il ya aussi ces personnes là qui
sont dans une misère y nuit du fait de
l'insécurité mais qui ne sont pas tout à
fait vivante parce que tout simplement
ils sont dans un des humains dans une
déshumanisation totale il est important
et je profite de votre plateau pour
lancer un plaidoyer que le monde entier
se tournent vers cette région qu'est le
sahel le ciel la zone des trois
frontières les trois pays ça fait à peu
près 60 9 millions d'habitants l'ukraine
à côté ça fait quarante trois millions
d'habitants un peu plus de 43 millions
d'habitants en l'espace de sept ans le
sahel avait besoin de 2,1 milliards
d'euros pour juguler réguler stopper la
montée en puissance des terroristes le
ciel de la page en l'espace de deux mois
de conflit russe le g7 et l'ensemble de
l'union européenne ont mobilisé près de
13 milliards bureau pour l'aide
humanitaire en russie est encore asseyez
vous madame je vais vous dire une chose
les jamais et un conflit la mobiliser
autant de dons en armement de facilité
en acquisition du munitions et
d'armements pour un seul pays en
l'espace de si peu du temps alors que là
le ciel crient au secours cherchent à
cerner à s'outiller les armes et du jus
du g5 ça elle cherche à se doter de
moyens beaucoup plus puissant mais
malheureusement il ya des difficultés
sur son chemin il est important que l'on
comprenne tous ensemble que tant que le
sahel ne sera pas en paix aucun pays
aussi loin soit il ne sera en paix et
j'ajoute que notre pays de la région
sont menacées ne l'oublions pas on n'a
malheureusement pas pas beaucoup de
temps donc j'ai encore une question à
vous poser notamment sur la rencontre
entre le président dany bas et l'ancien
président roch kaboré il semblait
amaigri tout d'abord comment va-t-il est
il libre de ses mouvements qu'elles sont
quel est son statut aujourd'hui c'est
vrai la question du président of mac
lissant kaboré est souvent posées voire
même instrumentaliser ou politisé il est
important de rappeler que le président
roh smoky un kaboré reste quand même une
cheville fondamental pour le retour à la
réconciliation du burkina faso et ce
geste qu'il a eu à faire d'humilité de
modestie mais aussi d'engagement pour la
paix au burkina faso en allant saluer
son homologue le président paul harris
un logo damiba est une leçon de vie que
ces deux là où ces trois là avec le
président jean baptiste donne à
l'ensemble de la jeunesse burkinabè je
voudrais dire ici encore une fois qu'il
est primordial important que l'on oublie
nos égos démesurés que l'on oublie nos
menus conflits personnels et que l'on
pense à l'intérêt supérieur du pays
qu'est le burkina faso ce qui se joue
dans notre pays c'est le père et ultime
même de notre nationalité de burkinabè
il est important que ces personnes la
suisse à lui qu'il se donne la main afin
que les une qui sont engagés derrière
eux un chien de faïence qui se regardent
plus ensemble embauché le même pas est
engagé cette réconciliation qui est
nécessaire c'est vrai le président roch
marc christian kaboré a une sécurité
fondamentale autour de lui mais les
discussions se poursuivent les
discussions sur fond et le lien su fait
la preuve en images ici que vous l'avez
vu alors il en résidence surveillée ou
pas quel est son statut officiel il ya
une sécurité autour justement du
président roch marc christian kaboré
vous savez que ce n'est pas n'importe
qui il a occupé de hautes fonctions dans
notre pays et ce qui s'est passé
récemment autorisé ou en tout cas est un
devoir pour le gouvernement d'assurer sa
sécurité et si vous savez que le
président comme acquise en cas bord a pu
rejoindre donc sa résidence de la patte
d'oie et pas cette résidence qui avait
été choisi par le gouvernement c'est
parce que le dialogue n'a jamais été
rompu merci beaucoup en tout cas d'être
venu nous voir merci infiniment
je rappelle que vous êtes le ministre de
l'éducation et porte-parole du
gouvernement merci beaucoup lionel gilgo
est votre message à la communauté
internationale et est passé
l'onu qui dénonce un usage excessif de
la force contre des migrants par le
maroc et l'espagne en fin de semaine
dernière amélie la halle enclave
espagnole sur le territoire marocain
usage de la force qui s'est traduit par
la mort de dizaines de personnes le
porte parole de l'onu stéphane dujarric
c'est s'est dit choqué par les images de
ces violences et appels à l'ouverture
d'une enquête le parquet espagnol a
annoncé l'ouverture d'une enquête par
ailleurs des migrants témoins de la
scène ont manifesté ce mardi à rabat au
maroc pour crier leur colère écoutez
nous nous sommes dirigés vers la ville
de nador ils nous ont gravement abbas et
le gouvernement marocain a déclaré qu'il
ya eu 23 morts mais nous pensons qu'il
ya eu plus que 70 ans
c'est inhumain tout ça on ne veut pas de
discrimination entre les migrants
beaucoup de ces événements n'ont pas été
filmée nous avons beaucoup de morts de
blessés et beaucoup de jeunes fonde en
prison nous demandons des associations
de droits de l'homme d'intervenir pour
soigner les blessés et nous demandons de
nous évacuer car ici nous ne sommes pas
en sécurité
ce qui est arrivé ce jour là c'est qu'il
y à une bousculade entre les migrants
qui voulaient traverser vers l'autre
côté vermelha les forces de l'ordre sont
intervenues pour les tabasser dans ce
qui a fait des morts parmi nos frères
nous demandons de voir les corps et de
les identifier informer leurs familles
au soudan de ce qui s'est passé
le climat préélectoral reste très tendue
au sénégal à moins d'un mois du scrutin
législatif un tribunal de dakar a
condamné mardi à une peine de six mois
de prison avec sursis un député
d'opposition pour avoir bravé une
interdiction de manifester et relaxé
dans le même dossier une autre député il
avait été arrêté le 17 juin dernier lors
d'une manifestation à l'appel de
l'opposition qui avaient été interdites
pour finir on part en egypte où il y à
moins d'une semaine le gouvernement a
émis l'ordre aux habitants d'une
trentaine de maisons bateaux d'évacuer
les lieux au plus tard le 4 juillet une
situation incompréhensible pour les
occupants de ces maisons à flottante qui
vivent là depuis des décennies reportage
de notre correspondant au caire edouard
dropsy
des maisons éventrées
d'autres déplacés les autorités
égyptiennes ont mis leurs injonctions
d'expulser les habitants d'une à
exécution à 88 ans irla si brahim
prépare ses cartons contre son gré mais
elle n'a pas arrangé les mets en 1997
elle a fait l'acquisition de cette
maison flottante pour retrouver les
souvenirs de son enfance déjà versés par
le nil mais il ya quelques jours le
gouvernement a décidé d'expulser tous
des habitants des maisons bateaux elle
est désespérée aux ja et moi
c'est ma maison ma vie
si je forme du cigem elles toutes ces
maisons sont concernées sept autres
hisser universitaire reconnue est rentré
il ya une dizaine d'années du royaume
uni après avoir parcouru le monde elle
avait enfin décidé de déposer ses
valises sur le nil
ils disent que nous pourrions le fleuve
et que nous étions un affront à l'aspect
civilisationnel du nil et c'est très
étrange parce que c'est une telle part
d'héritage
jérôme lui a passé une partie de son
enfance dans cette maison après des
études à l'étranger il a décidé de la
rénover son père vit toujours au caire
c'est pas trop dur non
[Musique]
ensemble ils souhaitent trouver une
solution avec le gouvernement conduit à
des projets commerciaux sur les berges
du nil contacté le gouvernement n'a pas
donné suite à nos demandes d'interview
on n'est pas du tout contre
développement on est même complètement
pour le seul problème c'est que on veut
être parent on veut faire partie de ce
développement si aucun compromis n'est
trouvé d'ici le 4 juillet ces maisons
centenaires finiront aux enchères au
dixième de leurs prix
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'afrique rester avec nous dans quelques
instants la suite de paris direct
[Musique]